a lot of people see our photo printing
business
as a sunset industry after 34 years or
so
and thankfully as well the sun has not
sat on us yet
so we have to develop new business
models and constantly revolutionize
our businesses the world is changing
it's changing at a much quicker pace
what got you here will not necessarily
get you there how do we evolve
to deliver an appropriate proposition
today businesses have to be agile and
stay relevant
amidst rapidly evolving conditions and
environments
in order to thrive in the marketplace to
effectively and proactively leverage
business opportunities
it is important to ask the right
questions understand
any root issues and know your customers
needs
before implementing solutions this is
critical to allocating resources
more efficiently and aligning the
pursuits of innovation
with the company's overall vision
photohub was founded as a small photo
print shop 24 years ago
today the business have evolved and
expanded into a total imaging solution
specialist
serving all business level from b to c b
to b
to b to g flow is a
luxury bedding and bath brand
headquartered here in singapore
what we look to do is to offer the best
sleep and bath experiences for our
clients around the world over the past
18 years
we've been able to develop a luxury
loving following
for this next part of our journey we
wanted to
make that move from the focus of luxury
hospitality
to that luxury consumer we had our
strategy
but it was how we were going to make
that happen that's where the frame and
scope project was quite
valuable for us when the frame and scope
program came along it was timely for us
as part of our transformation
and innovation process
the design for business frame and scope
scheme by design singapore council
and enterprise singapore helps companies
increase their competitiveness
expand into new markets and offerings
and prioritize specific areas to improve
on through design thinking
a user-centered approach to innovation
and problem solving
working together with a strategic design
consultancy
a company goes through three phases
within the frame and scope scheme
phase one is discover which allows
companies to develop a deep
understanding
and gain clarity on business priorities
and goals
existing or changing customer
demographics and psychographics
underlying needs and wants of these
customers
as well as the market and competitors
landscape
phase two is prioritize
when the consultants will work with the
company to leverage insights from phase
one
to develop a strategic roadmap of the
company's innovation plan
outlining a range of short to long term
priorities
finally phase three implement companies
can seek further support from enterprise
singapore to implement
recommendations outlined in the grant
proposal
which the consultants will help to draft
the frame and scope program has helped
us to understand
and appreciate the importance of success
by
design rather than hoping to achieve
success by chance
on the highest level help us to clarify
our thinking
are we addressing the questions are we
looking at the situation the markets the
opportunities and our customers
the design thinking approach is really
what's helping us
look into that in a way that we think is
going to be most effective
so with this understanding and
appreciation it does
and has helped us understand our
customers better
not just only the existing customers but
also the future one
this has in turn guide us in the
development of our future suite of
products and services
that to us is the probably the biggest
takeaway from this program
we had a great time with our design
consultant
he was really able to add sort of
another layer
to our own experience and knowledge
about our
consumer our brand the design
consultants they brought with them
not only insights in our industry but
also from the other industries
for smes out there who are seriously
thinking about transformation
i would urge them to give the frame and
scope program
serious consideration i would say just
take advantage of it immediately
i would say for those who are still
considering it continue to own
your brand continue to own your vision
and your strategy
but have an open mind to learn more
take action today to help your business
gain clarity
and pivot into new business models want
to find out more
drop us an email or visit our website